but just to say something more about
the scientist and and the back
propagation idea that you mentioned um
so
in in nineteen
hinton had been there as a postdoc and
organized that conference he'd actually
gone away and gotten an assistant
professorship and then
um there was this opportunity to bring
him back so jeff hinton was back
on a sabbatical san diego in san diego
and uh remember heart and i had decided
we wanted to do this
you know we thought it was really
exciting and
um our the papers on the interactive
activation model that i was telling you
about had just been published and we
both sort of saw a huge potential for
this work and
and and jeff was there and so the three
of us
uh
started a research group which we called
the pdp research group
and uh several other people
came um francis crick who was at the
sock institute heard about it from jeff
um and uh because jeff was known among
brits to be brilliant and francis was
well connected with his british connect
friends so
francis crick came and a heck of a group
of people wow okay and uh
uh several as paul spalensky um was one
of the other postdocs he was still there
as a postdoc
and um
a few other people but anyway
jeff
talk to us about
learning
and
how we should think about
how
you know learning occurs in a neural
network and he said
the problem
with the way you guys have been
approaching this is that you've been
looking for inspiration from biology
to tell you how
what the rules should be for how the
synapses should change the strengths of
their connections how the connections
should form
he said that's the wrong way to go about
it what you should do is you should
think in terms of
how you can
adjust connection weights
to solve
a problem
so you define your problem
and then you figure out
how the adjustment of the connection
weights will solve the problem
and
removal heart heard that
said to himself okay so i'm going to
start thinking about it that way i'm
going to
essentially
imagine that i have some objective
function
some goal of the computation i want my
machine to correctly classify all of
these images
and i can score that i can measure how
well they're doing on each image and i
get some measure of law error or loss
it's typically called in deep learning
and um
i'm going to figure out how to adjust
the connection weights so as to minimize
my loss or reduce the error
uh and
that's called
you know gradient descent
and uh
engineers were already uh familiar with
the concept of gradient descent
uh and in fact um
there was an algorithm
called the delta rule
that had been invented
by
a professor in the engineering
electoral engineering department at
stanford
woodrow bernie woodrow and a
collaborator named hoff i don't never
met him anyway so
so
gradient descent in continuous
neural networks with multiple
neuron-like processing units was already
understood
for a single layer of connection weights
we have some inputs over a set of
neurons we want the output to produce a
certain pattern
we can define the difference between our
target and what the narrow network is
producing and we can figure out how to
change the connection weights to reduce
that error
so what rommelhard did was to generalize
that
so as to be able to change the
connections from earlier layers of units
to the ones
at a hidden layer between the input and
the output
and
so he first called the algorithm the
generalized delta rule because it's just
an extension of the gradient descent
idea
and interestingly enough
hinton was thinking that this wasn't
going to work very well
so hinton had his own alternative
algorithm at the time
based on uh the concept of the balsa
machine that he was pursuing so the
paper on the balsa machine came out in
learning in bolster machines came out in
but it turned out that
backprop worked better than the bolster
machine learning algorithm
so this generalized delta algorithm
ended up being called back propagation
as you say back prop yeah
and
the you know probably that name is
opaque to maybe what what does that mean
what it what it meant was that in order
to figure out what the changes you
needed to make to the
connections from the input to the hidden
layer
you had to
back propagate the error signals
from the output layer through the
connections
from the hidden layer to the
output to get the signals
that would be the error signals for the
hidden layer
and that's how rimmel hard formulated it
was like well we know what the air
signals are at the output layer let's
see if we can get a signal at the hidden
layer that tells each hidden unit what
its air signal is essentially so it's
back propagating through the connections
from the hidden to the output to get the
signals to tell the hidden units how to
change their weights from the input and
that's why it's called back problems
yeah but uh so it
came from hinton having
introduced the concept of you know
define your objective function figure
out how to
take the derivative so that you can um
adjust the connections so that they make
progress towards your goal so stop
thinking about biology for a second and
let's start to think about optimization
and computation yeah a little bit more
so
what about
jeff hinton
what um
you've gotten a chance to work with him
in that little
the set of people involved there is
quite incredible the small set of people
under the the pdp flag
it's just given the amount of impact
those ideas have had over the years it's
kind of incredible to think about but
you know
just like you said uh like yourself
jeffrey hinton is seen as one of the
not just like a seminal figure in ai but
just a brilliant person just a like the
horsepower of the mind is pretty high up
there for him because he's
just a great thinker so what kind of
ideas have you
um
learned from him have you influenced
each other on have you debated over what
stands out to you
in in the in the full space of ideas
here
at the intersection of computation and
cognition
well
so um
jeff has said many things to me that had
a profound impact on my thinking
um and he's written several articles
which
were way ahead of their time
he
he had two papers in 1981 just to give
one example
one of which was essentially the idea of
transformers
and another of which
was a
early paper on semantic cognition which
inspired
him and rommel hart and me
[Music]
throughout
the 80s and
uh um
you know still uh i think sort of
grounds my own thinking about
um the semantic aspects of of cognition
um
he also
uh in a in a small paper that was never
published that he wrote in 1977 you know
before he actually arrived at ucsd or
maybe a couple of years even before that
i don't know
uh when he was a phd student he he um
described how a neural network could
uh do recursive computation
and um
uh
it was a very clever idea that he's
continued to explore over time which was
sort of the idea that
um
when you when you call a subroutine you
need to save the state that you had
when you called it so you can get back
to where you were when you're finished
with the subroutine and and the idea was
that you would save the state
of the calling routine by making fast
changes to connection weights
and then
when you
finished with the subroutine call those
fast changes in the connection weights
would allow you to go back to where you
had been before
and reinstate the previous context so
that you could continue on with the
the
the top level of the computation
anyway that was part of the idea and um
i always thought okay that's really you
know he just
he had extremely creative ideas that
were
quite a lot ahead of his time and
many of them in the 1970s and early
early 1980s
so
another thing about jeff hinton's way of
thinking which um has profoundly
influenced my
um
uh effort to understand human
mathematical cognition
is
that he doesn't write too many equations
and people tell stories like oh in
in the hints and lab meetings you don't
get up at the board and write equations
like you do in everybody else's machine
learning lab
what you do is you draw a picture
and and you know he he explains
aspects of the way deep learning works
by
putting his hands together and showing
you the shape of a ravine
and um
using that as a geometrical metaphor for
the
what's happening as this gradient
descent process you're coming down the
wall of a ravine if you take too big a
jump you're gonna jump to the other side
and um so that's why we have to turn
down the learning rate uh for example um
and
it it
speaks to me of the
fundamentally intuitive character of
deep insight
together with
a commitment to really understanding
um
in a way that's
absolutely ultimately explicit and clear
uh
but also intuitive
yeah there's certain people like that
here's an example
some kind of weird mix of uh visual
and intuitive and all those kinds of
things feynman is another example
different style thinking but very unique
and when you when you're around those
people for me in the engineering realm
uh there's a guy named jim keller
who's a chip designer engineer
every time i talk to him
it doesn't matter what we're talking
about just
having experienced that unique way of
thinking transforms you and makes your
work much better
and that's that's the magic you look at
daniel kahneman you look at the great
collaborations throughout the history of
science
that's the magic of that it's not always
the exact ideas that you talk about
but it's the process of generating those
ideas being around that spending time
with that human being you can come up
with some brilliant work especially when
it's cross-disciplinary as it was a
little bit in your case yeah jeff
yeah um
jeff is uh a descendant of
the logician bool
he comes from a long line of
english
and
together with the
um
deeply intuitive thinking ability that
he has he also
um
has
you know it's been clear he's he's
described this to me um and i think he's
mentioned it from time to time in other
interviews with that he's had with
people um you know he's
he's wanted to be able to sort of think
of himself as contributing to the
to the
understanding of
reasoning itself not just human
reasoning like bull like is about logic
right it's about
what can we conclude from what else and
how do we formalize that and
um as a computer scientist uh
logician
philosopher you know um the goal is to
understand how we derive truths from
other
from givens and things like this and and
the work that jeff was doing in the
um early to mid 80s um
on something called the boltzmann
machine was uh his way of
connecting with that boolean tradition
and bringing it
into the more continuous probabilistic
graded constraint satisfaction realm
um and it was
it was um
beautiful uh
a set of ideas linked with theoretical
physics um and
um
as well as with logic and um
it it's always been i mean i've always
been inspired by the bolson machine too
it's it's like well if the neurons are
probabilistic rather than
you know deterministic in their
computations then
you know that that maybe this uh somehow
is part of the
um
serendipity or you know
adventitiousness of the moment of
insight right
the it it might not have occurred at
that particular instant it might be sort
of partially the result of a stochastic
process
and uh
and and that too is part of the magic of
the emergence of uh
some of these things well you're right
with the bullying lineage and the the
dream of computer science
is uh somehow
i mean i certainly think of humans this
way that humans are one particular
manifestation of intelligence
that there's something bigger going on
and you're trying to you're hoping to
figure that out
the mechanisms of intelligence the
mechanisms of cognition are much bigger
than just humans yeah so i think of um
i've i started using the phrase
computational intelligence at some point
as to characterize the
the field that i thought you know people
like jeff hinton
um and many of the
of the people i know at deepmind um
are are working in and where i i feel
like i'm
um
you know i'm a i'm a kind of a
human-oriented
computational intelligence researcher in
that i'm actually kind of interested in
the human solution
but at the same time i
uh
i feel like
that's that's where um a huge amount of
the
the excitement of deep learning actually
lies is in the idea that
you know we may be able to even go
beyond what we can achieve with our own
nervous systems when we
build
um computational intelligences that are
um
you know not limited in the ways that we
are by our own biology perhaps allowing
us to scale the very mechanisms of human
intelligence just increase its power
through scale
yes
and and i think that that you know
obviously that's the
that's being played out massively at
google brain at open ai and to some
extended deep mind as well um
i guess i shouldn't say to some extent
uh the the the massive scale of the um
computations that uh
are used to
succeed at games like go or to solve the
protein folding problems that they've
been solving and so on still not as many
uh synapses and neurons as the human
brain so we still got
we're still still beating them on that
we humans are beating the ais but
they're catching up pretty quickly
you